Tao is a 2018 Netflix original science
fiction horror movie starring Michael
Monroe ed skrein and Gary Oldman as an
evil version of Alexa the movie centers
around Monroe's character being
kidnapped and experimented on whilst the
film is receiving mixed reviews it still
has quite a thought-provoking narrative
and it's ending leaves a lot to unpack
throughout this video I will be
discussing the ending of Tao so there
will be heavy spoilers without the way
I'm definition and this is my ending
explanation of Tao
Taos creator Alex informs Julia that
this serie on steroids is technological
magnum opus and it is an automated
sentience so advanced AI must be cut off
from the world to prevent it from
exceeding safe limitation unable to
advance his projects any further alex
has been kidnapping human subjects and
using them as guinea pigs a true
psychopath he is completely blind to
their suffering and his goals are always
on the finalization of his creations
rather than compassion fitting her with
a neural implant alex is collecting data
on Julia as she participates and puzzles
and he is using this information to
create more advancements to his AI
systems Julia was picked because of her
past traumas and she accedes where
others have failed because of her
ability to bond with Tao and during the
film's runtime she attempts to escape
her captor through hacking and using Tao
to her advantage
I believe that Julia was picked because
of Alex's view on humanity we see that
early on Julia is a thief and represents
a darker side of society that Alex would
be attracted to people are also less
likely to care about someone who makes
their living like this and he knows that
police will probably take less of an
interest in her disappearance he also
suspects that because she does wicked
things she will be a wicked person but
his backfires when Tao becomes curious
in the girl as towers learning from
Julia I begin
to pick up some of their more redeeming
traits enough she is able to use the
machine to escape
however she returns when Alex takes
revenge on Tao deleting all of his
memories in the process as Alex prepares
to extract her implant Julia frees
herself with the help of one of Taos
mini drones that was disconnected prior
to the eurasia she activates a
self-destruct sequence to destroy the
house and Alex is killed in the collapse
emerging from the home with the mini
drone in hand she walks into the sunset
promising to shout out the world this
signifies to me that julia has grown
with the machine and just in the way
that it allowed her to escape she has
done the same for it I believe that Taos
memories have actually remained intact
and that their bond will continue this
is because Alex removed a chip from the
drone with one wing to add to his
service day and it's likely that it was
subsequently disconnected allowing Taos
memories to stay intact one question
that I've seen asked on message boards
is why did Alex have a self-destruct
button in the first place while some of
the arize that this is due to the fact
that he had a lot of secret work that he
didn't want discovered I disagree
personally I believe that his fear of
Tao caused him to create countermeasures
to stop the AI getting out as he knew
that should the technology see some of
the atrocities that humanity partakes in
it may attempt to wipe them out
this is why Julia makes the perfect
counterpart to the machine
she shows that trauma does not define
someone and will most likely be able to
curb the machines understanding of the
world in a way that they're
dispassionate Alex couldn't in the end
machines are only what we programmed
them to be able to do and therefore
Julia's positive influence will
ultimately have a positive effect on it
which will then in turn have a positive
effect
the world which is a nice message to
take away especially when so many pieces
of media sent it around artificial
intelligence off of the negative so what
did you think of Tao do you agree with
the critics that it was a sci-fi
disaster or do you think there were some
redeeming qualities of the film comment
below and let me know and if you like
this video please like it and subscribe
to my channel as I create ending
explained videos weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film make sure
you check out my breakdown at the
post-credits scene about man in the wasp
at the end of this video come on you
avoided all those infinity war spoilers
you deserve it
again thanks very much for taking the
time to watch this and I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]